sage propose maintenant une exposition
ça se passe au musée de la marine à
paris
n'est ce pas antoine à mille sabords une
exposition consacrée à tintin haddock et
les innombrables bateau qu'ils ont
empruntée au cours de leur aventure et
on y découvre entre autres le goût des
rg
pour les détails antoine cormery et
daniel levy nous permet de nous
embarquer dans ce reportage au musée de
la marine parmi les portraits d'avenir
au célèbre île en étant dénote un peu le
chevalier françois de hadoque illustre
aïeul capitaine et son fier vaisseau la
licorne
voguant dans les eaux des caraïbes
infestées de pirates
je viens rackham le rouge la licorne
hergé ne l'a pas inventé la preuve voici
le brillant vaisseau français de 60 cas
non construits en 16190 c'est cette
maquette du musée de la marine qui a
servi de modèle
r j'ai travaillé d'une manière
extrêmement précise et plus il avançait
dans les albums qu'il a dessinés et
surtout à partir du début des années 40
il a commencé à chercher une
documentation extrêmement scientifique
et il est notamment entrer en relation
avec le musée national de la marine
il est venu il a écrit le musée lui a
envoyé des photographies que l'on a
retrouvée d'ailleurs dans ces dossiers à
bruxelles
c'était vraiment un grand moment
d'émotion des documents qui venait de
paris
et si l'exposition se tient au musée de
la marine c'est que l'univers d'hergé
est peuplé de paquebots de cargos de
contrebande baleinier de chalutiers et
même de sous marins de poche le
perfectionnisme de son coup de crayon
lui fera même mettre au goût du jour
certains équipements maritimes comme
cette vignette d'un poste de radio
corrigé à trois reprises au fil des
progrès techniques avec de nombreuses
pièces originales comme ses aquarelles
où ces crayonné les teintes idéologues
avertis y trouveront donc leur compte
mais le jeune public aussi grâce à une
mise en scène ludique de l'univers
d'hergé en gros une exposition à voir de
7 à 77 ans mais mille millions de ca
bord vous avez apporté des objets
antoine je ne suis pas venu les mains
vides vieira et vous c'est quelques
temps justement je sais a porté sur ce
plateau des reliques d'une sainte et
bien pour les gens qui aiment tintin
finalement ça ça peut être considéré
aussi comme des reliques
regardez ça c'est un casque de
scaphandres modèle extrêmement rare de
1895 en cuivre a vraiment un très très
bel objet et pourquoi ça a un rapport
avec tintin parce que c'est précisément
ce casque de scaphandres la 4g a dessiné
dans le trésor de rackham le rouge
vous allez le voir sur ce dessin en gros
plan voici ici même et bien tintin
revêtus de ce casque de scaphandres
c'est un modèle très rare donc hergé
s'est directement inspiré de ce modèle
que le musée de la marine nous apprêter
et ça ça c'est la fondation hergé qui
nous a prêté sa sas est rarissime c'est
une planche originale du trésor de
rackham le rouge la numéro 40 exactement
pour pour les experts parce qu'il ya des
experts elle est conservée
habituellement dans les coffres de la
fondation hergé à bruxelles
elle a été dessinée en 1944 et si vous
allez faire une petite comparaison avec
l'album d'hergé vous pouvez avoir chez
vous du trésor de rackham un jour où
l'avez-vous regarderai ça cet après midi
tintin dans ce dessin original du tout
début nous fait face
il s'éloigne
l'épave de la licorne et vous regarderez
que dans votre bande dessinée avoue
versions ultérieures et bien il va vers
la licorne donc hergé a simplement
modifié son personnage donc ça c'est
rarissime
et puis quelque chose d'original aussi
je vous parlais de la licorne voici ici
la maquette de la licorne alors elle ne
date pas de l'époque d'hergé mais il ya
un telle fascination autour des rg
autour de tintin que aujourd'hui les
amateurs reconstruisent la licorne
bateau qui n'ait jamais existé
d'après un dessin d'hergé ça c'est une
maquette toute récente qui illustre la
ferveur autour de tintin figurez vous
qu'on vend chaque année en langue
française un million d'albums de tintin
l'exposition du musée de la marine est
là pour faire partager cette ferveur
sachez que la fondation hergé multiplie
les expositions il y en aura une au
château de cheverny en juin prochain
pourquoi cheverny parce que si vous êtes
un amoureux de tintin cheverny c'est le
château qui a inspiré moulin hasard
hergé a juste enlever les bergers a
juste enlever les les ailes latérales
merci en douane or l'algérie dans la
boulangerie la boucherie